although the majority of Marvel actors
seem to enjoy playing their roles in the
franchise a number of stars have ended a
pretty upset with how their scenes or
even whole movies turned out here are a
few things Marvel movie actors have
seriously regretted having to do burn
actor who is known as much for his
muscular physique as he is for his
acting it might come as a surprise to
find that Chris Hemsworth doesn't
actually enjoy filming scene shirtless
especially if it wasn't in the script
speaking about his time on 2013's Thor
the dark world
Hemsworth told MTV that is shirtless
scene was mandated by Joss Whedon
Hemsworth said he just said there needed
to be something romantic in there then
he said Chris get your shirt off I said
well I don't know what's the why what
are we doing the justification was that
it was him coming home from battle
washing blood off his hands it is what
it is it's like as mussels are made of
cotati metal fibers stop massaging his
muscles but he was even more upset
during filming on thor ragnarok since he
felt including yet another shirtless
scene for thor was verging on becoming
exploitative Hemsworth said this time
around there wasn't one in the script
which I was really happy about then
director Taika Waititi said no I think
we need a shirt off scene I was like ugh
we've done that don't make me do it
again I just think it has to be
different each time you have an
obligation to mix it up and advance it
in some way Avengers infinity war opens
on the aftermath of a fierce battle
between the survivors of Asgard's
destruction and Thanos as the heroes
unsuccessfully attempt to stop Thanos
from claiming the tesseract from Loki
Loki's attempt to trick and kill thanos
fails however and Thanos brutally chokes
Loki to death
unlike Loki's many previous deaths this
one actually sticks and the sequence
sets a bleak tone for one of the darker
installments in the MCU who
resurrections this time for Thanos
killing the god of mischief might have
been just another day at the office but
it was a good deal harder to process for
the man playing him Josh Brolin later
told USA Today he had been with that
character for so long and he's so lauded
for doing it tom was so vulnerable at
that moment so choking him out wasn't
the most fun thing I've ever done in the
early days of the MCU Clint Barton often
came under fire by fans for being a
little vanilla in terms of character
development but Hawkeye actor Jeremy
Renner had his own problems when it came
the character's presence in the Avengers
during the movie Hawkeye has barely been
on screen for a minute before he's put
under Loki's spell talking to GamesRadar
Renner later said for 90% of the movie
I'm not the character I signed on to
play it's kind of a vacancy I was
limited you know what I mean I was a
terminator in a way fun stunts but is
there any sort of emotional content or
thought process
no conveniently enough Deadpool actor
Ryan Reynolds is one of the characters
biggest fanboys and was himself the
producer who finally brought the
wisecracking assassin to the screen
after many years of trying maximal
mentor but it's easy to forget that Ryan
Reynolds played Wade Wilson years before
his solo film with his small role in
x-men origins Wolverine as Reynolds told
People magazine it was a very
frustrating experience
I was already attached to the Deadpool
movie we hadn't at that point written a
script yet origins came along and it was
sort of like play Deadpool in this movie
or we'll get someone else to and I just
said I'll do it but it's the wrong
version Deadpool isn't correct in it to
make matters worse x-men origins was
filming during the writers strike of
2007 and 2008 so Reynolds had to write
his own lines
he explained so we were in the middle of
production there were no writers no
anything every line I have in the movie
I just wrote myself because in the
script we had it said Wade Wilson shows
up talks really fast I was like what
what am I supposed to do with that
that's understandably frustrating but
let's be honest letting Ryan Reynolds
ad-lib his way through the film maybe
the only thing that made it watchable
you look really nice today it's the
green brings out the seriousness in your
eyes you ever shut up pal no like his
predecessor in the role Sir Ian McKellen
Michael Fassbender brought a wealth of
stage presence to his betrayal of
traumatized Holocaust survivor erik
lensherr and his alter ego the morally
ambiguous mutant magneto Fassbender gave
the character a whole new level of
humanity and x-men first class but by
2016 - x-men Days of Future past he was
no longer happy with his work in the
role and even became visibly embarrassed
when scenes from the film aired at the
Toronto International Film Festival in
particular he hated the scene that saw
him and professor axe getting into an
argument in a plane you know this scene
where were you Charles
we were supposed to protect them what
were you when your own people needed you
vulture reported Fassbender is saying I
don't actually like that performance
there to be honest I just think it's
meat shouting it's just like some dude
shouting the Fantastic Four franchise
has struggled with a series of setbacks
and disappointments over the years such
as those experienced by Jessica Alba who
almost quit acting after playing Sue
Storm in 2007's Fantastic Four rise of
the Silver Surfer
according to sci-fi Alba explained the
director was like can you be prettier
when you cry don't do that thing with
your face just make it flat we can CGI
the tears in and then it got me thinking
am I not good enough or my instincts and
my emotions not good enough do people
hate them so much that they don't want
me to be a person and so I just said it
I don't care about this business anymore
Hugo Weaving has played a part in some
of the biggest movie franchises in
history including Lord of the Rings The
Hobbit and The Matrix franchises so it
makes perfect sense that an actor of his
caliber would also find a place in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which he
quickly did when he played the villain
Red Skull and Captain America the First
Avenger unfortunately while he was glad
to have it go he didn't exactly enjoy
the experience we've been told Collider
it's not something I would want to do
again I think I've done my - with that
sort of film it was good to do it and
try it out but to be honest it's not the
sort of film I seek out and really am
excited by we being added that he signed
a multi picture deal and said Marvel
could have forced him to reprise the
role but also pointed out that it would
have been pretty silly to force a
performer to show up for a project they
don't want to be in
Mickey Rourke was an absolute scene
stealer is Yvonne Banco an Iron Man -
Rourke brought an underlying empathy and
humanity to the role that makes his
performance incredibly compelling but he
told Screen Rant that the way Vaughn
code was written was far too
one-dimensional for his taste he
explained the bad guy doesn't always
have to be one-dimensional you know the
performance I tried to bring to Van Co
ends up on the floor that could cause
you not to care as much not to want to
put that effort in when you try to make
it an intelligent bad guy this character
was hard because he was written as pure
evil unlike many of his colleagues who
loved being a part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe idris elba has told
The Telegraph that plain Heimdall in the
MCU movies quickly became a chore for
him after spending eight months in South
Africa making
Nelson Mandela biopic Mandela Elva added
that coming back to shoot scenes for
Thor the dark world was torture
explaining I was actually falling down
from a spaceship so they had to put me
on a harness in this green screen studio
and in between takes I was stuck there
fake hair stuck to my head with this
glue this helmet while they reset and
I'm thinking 24 hours ago I was Mandela
then there I was in the stupid harness
with this wig and the sword in these
contact lenses it ripped my heart out
Tobey Maguire and Andrew Garfield both
may have played spider-man within a few
years of each other but only the latter
came out of the experience seriously
unhappy among other regrets Garfield
said that he thought his scenes in
character development were all wrong
I signed up to serve the story and so
this incredible character that I've been
dressing as since I was three yeah it
gets compromised and it breaks it breaks
my heart
Garfield blamed this misuse of the
character on the big-budget nature of
the movies as well as the capitalist
machine that is more interested in
making money than content we're still
young enough to to struggle with the the
value system I suppose of of Corporate
America
really Garfield soon exited the role
after a pair of films and was replaced
by another British actor Tom Holland who
took up the web-shooters and Captain
America Civil War Marvel took a long
time trying to find a version of Hulk
that works for audiences and critics
alike before finally hitting paydirt
with Mark Ruffalo's now iconic portrayal
of the character
if they are freaking out before Ruffalo
took the part however the studio
suffered a serious disappointment with
the Incredible Hulk in 2008 which
starred Edward Norton as the title
character a few years after leaving the
MCU Norton told the audience at Bruce
Willis's Comedy Central Roast that he
had encountered problems onset because
he quote wanted a better script I
thought maybe we should try to make one
Marvel movie that was at least as good
as the worst Chris Nolan movie but what
the hell was I thinking he also claimed
that he was invited to help improve the
script but Marvel renig either way the
end result failed to live up to
expectations the bad blood between
Marvel and its erstwhile Hulk actor is
apparently mutual - in a statement prior
to the release of The Avengers Marvel
announced we have made the decision to
not bring Ed Norton back to portray the
title role of Bruce Banner our decision
is definitely not one based on monetary
factors but instead rooted in the need
for an actor who embodies the creativity
and collaborative spirit of our other
talented cast members long before he
played Batman into DC eu Ben Affleck
starred in one of the lesser loved
Marvel adaptations as lawyer by day
vigilante by night Matt Murdock also
known as daredevil unlike some of the
other Marvel inspired bombs that later
turned into cult classics applix
daredevil has yet to find any kind of
adoration from Marvel fans in fact it's
mostly been forgotten but its star
doesn't mind that one bit speaking to
Playboy magazine Affleck said the only
movie I actually regret is daredevil it
just kills me I love that story that
character and the fact that it got
dumped the way it does stays with me
maybe that's part of the motivation to
do Batman unfortunately when he was
announced as the new Batman it was his
performance in daredevil that had fans
concerned about his ability to pull off
the role at the time the actor said if I
thought the results would be another
daredevil I'd be out there picketing
myself why would I make the movie if I
didn't think it was going to be good
long before Howard the Duck made his
brief cameos and the guardians of the
galaxy movies he made his full-length
feature film debut in 1986 is Howard the
Duck this was the story of a parallel
universe where an alien anthropomorphic
duck is brought to earth after an
accident on his planet and the whole
thing turned out a little raunchy er
than most Marvel movies no more mr. nice
duck when asked about her role as
Howard's love interest Beverly in Howard
the Duck star Lea Thompson told The
Hollywood Reporter I was the number one
star of it it was painful
among many other truly bizarre things
that happened in the movie Howard the
Duck also features an intimate scene
between Thompson and Howard which is as
graphic as innuendo can get without
veering straight into bestiality is it
any wonder she didn't enjoy it check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you